ever since apple announced the
transition to their own apple silicon
chips ditching intel they have been in a
huge feud going back and forth jabbing
at each other with intel actually hiring
the i'm a mac guy and then going as far
as to hire apple's own engineer that led
the transition from intel base max to
apple silicon so they're going at it for
the last couple of years but it looks
like apple is finally getting the leg up
with some major changes to what's
happening in the laptop chip world so
let's get right into it but before i get
into all of that let me go through some
of what's going on with their chips
right now to give us some context for
what's about to be happening earlier
this year intel unveiled their alder
lake chips for their laptops which ended
up basically outperforming apple's best
m1 max chip in their 16 inch macbook pro
now that's very impressive however they
had to do it by using a lot of power in
an antex review of the m1 max tom's
hardware pointed out that when they were
testing the core i9 12900 hk which is
the best alder lake intel chip it
consumed up to 94 watts from the wall
compared to an antex review of the m1
max that only consumed 39.7
watts that's almost two and a half more
times power to just barely be faster
than the m1 max but not only that we
actually compared this i9 12 900 hk chip
to apples m1 max but the crazy thing is
we used the 14 inch macbook pro which is
known to have a little bit of thermal
throttling compared to the 16 inch and
guess what in multiple tests real world
test the m1 max was actually beating out
the older lake in the ge76 chassis which
is a thick chassis but the craziest
thing of all was when we tested the
battery life with the m1 max getting 20
hours of video playback compared to 4.5
on that alder lake laptop or
7 hours video rendering compared to only
2.5 in our testing and that actually
matches the testing of tom's hardware as
well because their macbook pro lasted 15
and a half hours compared to only four
hours and five minutes in the same
environment for the ge 76 raider the
same intel laptop that we tested but now
making it worse it looks like intel's
upcoming raptor lake generation of chips
uses even more power than alder lake for
example showing off the different sizes
of the desktop chips but of course this
power usage is also gonna translate to
the laptops as well so they're gonna use
even more power than they already do so
because of that intel was planning to
use tsmc's next-gen 3 nanometer process
node for their future meteor lake chips
but unfortunately once again it looks
like intel is postponing and delaying it
again because looking at the source
trend force here's what they said they
said mass production of this product was
initially planned for the second half of
2022 but was later postponed to the
first half of 2023 due to product design
and process verification issues recently
the product's mass production schedule
has been postponed again to the end of
2023 for some reason almost completely
cancelling three nanometer production
capacity originally booked in 2023 with
only a marginal amount of wafer input
remaining for engineering verification
so based on that it seems like intel's
not gonna have their next meteor lake
chips ready until
2024. but here's where things get very
interesting especially on the apple side
tsmc came out and they commented on
those rumors about intel canceling their
three nanometer orders and they said
that tsmc does not comment on the
business of individual customers the
company's capacity expansion product is
proceeding as planned so yes it looks
like even though intel is delaying three
nanometer for their own meteor like
chips tsmc is not delaying anything
they're still pushing and planning the
same capacity that they were gonna make
anyway for three nanometer and i know
why way back in april it was reported
that tsmc was planning to start three
nanometer chip production in the second
half of this year which is 2022
but then in june we got this monster
report from jeff poo saying that tsmc is
going to start producing apple's m2 pro
chip later this year which is going to
be on
tsmc three nanometer yes three nanometer
not five nanometers so i made a video
talking about all of that talking about
how three nanometers going to be like
what kind of performance differences
there should be and then after i made
that video we got another report from
digitime saying that the upcoming m2 pro
chip for the high-end macbook pro and
mac mini will be using three nanometer
yes the same three nanometer that intel
was supposed to use up but they delayed
it and cancelled almost all of their
orders and because of that it started
sparking some discussion about the m2
pro and m2 max chip offering massive
performance leaps over the m2 because a
lot of people were expecting the m2 pro
and max to be based on the same five
nanometer architecture that the m2 is
based on but i disagree i think it's
gonna be three nanometer and because of
that the performance is gonna be crazy
and a big reason i believe these next m2
pro and max chips are going to be based
on three nanometer is because apple is
gonna be essentially the only major
company left to take tsmc's three
nanometer capacity because intel
cancelled so if apple doesn't switch to
three nanometer early next year and they
weights who is going to take the first
wave of three nanometer basically nobody
and tsmc has already confirmed that
everything's going as scheduled they're
not gonna delay three nanometer i think
that's because the m2 pro and max are
gonna be on three nanometer now i did
speak to mark german about the next gen
14 and 16-inch macbook pros that we
should be expecting and according to him
those machines are gonna have the same
design on the outside so no design
changes at all which means that the
changes will be coming to the inside and
in my opinion i don't think it's enough
to give us the same five nanometer base
chips i don't think that's going to be a
big improvement because if you didn't
already know the m2 chip uses
significantly more power than the m1 in
fact in cinebench we saw that it uses 36
percent more average power to only get
13 more score which basically shows that
the m2 chip is overclocked like crazy on
that five nanometer architecture and if
you've seen our coverage last year of
the 14 and 16 inch macbook pros you'll
know that the highest end m1 max chip is
too much for the 14 inch chassis yes it
thermal throttles and it slows down
performance when you have a maxed out
version in fact if you get the 16 inch
macbook pro with the 24 core gpu it's
actually faster throughout multiple
tests than the 32 core version in the 14
inch chassis yes that's because of
thermal throttling it's not able to
handle a heat so imagine if apple made
the m2 pro and m2 max on five nanometer
again which is gonna suck up a lot of
power i don't think that's happening i
think apple is planning to switch to
three nanometer and because of that i
think intel is in trouble because intel
keeps delaying meteor lake and i think
it's gonna take meteor lake to finally
compete with apple silicon because
raptor lake is gonna consume power like
crazy they're not gonna have that three
nanometer gpu tile so i feel like intel
is gonna be struggling until meteor lake
comes out and i don't think that's
happening until 2024 so i think these
next macbook pros that we're gonna get
are gonna be insane they're going to be
amazing the performance is going to be
crazy and they're not going to heat up
as much as they did before especially as
much as if apple's stuck to five
nanometers so if you disagree with me
let me know down in the comment section
below but if you agree click that circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and check out one of those two
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]